meanwhile lafleur and warmock are
attacking each other over calls to end
the practice of cash bail and criminal
cases making law and order
a central theme of the campaign joining
us now with reaction
south carolina senator tim scott welcome
to you senator how are you
i'm doing well congressman how are you
tonight i'm doing fantastic
so tell us what's at stake in january in
georgia it seems like a lot
there's a whole lot at stake trade
there's no doubt when you think of the
elections in georgia it's not simply
controlling the senate
it's controlling the legislative agenda
for america
the two sides cannot be further apart
one side wants a four
trillion dollar tax increase and the way
you get that
win two seats in georgia our side lower
taxes by more than a trillion dollars
what that means trey for the average
person listening
is a sixty percent increase in your
taxes for single moms
a seventy percent increase in your taxes
it means
the ability to add more justices to the
supreme court
we've had nine justices for the last 150
years
they want to stack the courts so that
they can continue
to transform america into a socialist
utopia it just can't happen when we win
those two seats we will be funding the
police
not what the democrats want to do is
defund the police
this is the most consequential two
senate seats
in all of america at all time we
save the nation and continue to move in
the right direction
by having those two seats won by two
republicans
on january the fifth i'm going to spend
a lot of time trying to make that happen
i think you've already you've been
you've spent a lot of time in georgia i
think you
you you helped a couple of weeks ago
didn't you do you think it would be
helpful for the president to go to
georgia between now and the runoffs
uh you're right i spent some time
working for kelly leffler on her
campaign as well as david perdue but
there
there is only one giant in the party
and that is president donald trump
donald trump comes to
our great state of georgia and here's
what happens president trump has a
chance to talk about
his enormous support for historically
black colleges and universities
one of the reasons why president trump's
african-american numbers went up by
50 percent this election cycle is
because he
brought the highest level of funding to
hbcus made the funding permanent
he passed criminal justice reform making
up for the disaster
of the 1994 crime bill brought to you by
joe biden he's the one who made sure
that we focus on sickle cell anemia
research but for
every single georgian he brought tax
reform
he reset the regulatory state so that we
created more jobs
not lost more jobs president trump
is the person that makes sure those two
seats
remain in the republican column in the
senate
all right senator we've got about a
minute and a half left and i do want to
ask you by thanksgiving but it's not
just legislation i mean the rules of the
senate committee chairs
subcommittee chairs i mean that that's
at stake in a couple of weeks too isn't
it
without any question the end of the
filibuster is if we lose these two seats
they
destroy the filibuster so they can get
those legislation
priorities done but more importantly can
you imagine
bernie sanders as the chairman of the
budget
or elizabeth warren on the banking
committee becoming the subcommittee
chairman
of the consumer protection and financial
institutions
or senator hirono on the judiciary
committee
being the chairwoman of the constitution
the best lights out for our nation we
have to have a firewall
for america and that firewall starts and
ends
with those two seats uh in georgia
consequences the answer to all of your
questions is no i cannot imagine that
and i do not want to imagine that
i want to end on a happy note uh
tomorrow's thanksgiving i am very very
thankful for you and for your friendship
over the past decade what will you be
celebrating and giving thanks for
tomorrow
well one of the most important things
i'm thankful for is i have the good pr
good privilege of being born on the same
day as your mom and so we
share that self that that birth thing we
celebrate it uh together and
i look forward to wishing her a happy
thanksgiving tomorrow but i'm also
so thankful that my mom uh is covet free
i'm thankful that i live in a country
and in a community
in a state south carolina that believes
in second chances as a guy
who almost failed out of high school
having that second chance
brought to me by the good lord and the
people of south carolina
has meant the world to me and to my
family having a chance to be a
contributing member
of the south carolina family and of
america what a blessing
second chances something to remember
amen to second chances thank you senator
i hope you and your mama have a blessed
thanksgiving tomorrow